[Music]
so some pilots managed to land a plane
safely after hitting a huge flock of
birds during landing holy [ __ ] i've
always i've always thought like i'm
surprised that doesn't happen more often
actually i'm surprised they don't show
more often but like we're talking like
holy oh [ __ ] wait what the [ __ ] [ __ ] god
what is that a [ __ ] dinosaur [ __ ]
like that's pterodactyl [ __ ] [ __ ]
splattered birds dude do they have
windshield wipers i don't know how the
flames could ask your question because
like if [ __ ] like that happens right how
do they land
that's i think that's that's why this is
news
yeah right
i feel like they got windshield wipers
like i think i've seen it before i have
to because they can't just go like this
and [ __ ] dude i don't know they're going
like hella fast i think they just 500
miles an hour just blows it off i think
but that didn't blow off though the
windshield wiper real quick took it
right when it hit yeah
so as pilots have managed to safely land
this plane in italy despite having
nearly the entire windscreen covered in
bird guts wow so it never came off our
guts or guts yeah i mean so they hit
birds and then they died birds aren't
just feathers you know what i mean i
thought it was just bird [ __ ] just
dropping around their [ __ ] bird [ __ ]
just a coordinated bird [ __ ] attack
there's a telephone pole they're just
[ __ ] on the
bird anatomy according to joe there's no
organs it's just bird poop
inside of this
yeah birds are made out of poop no my
innocent mind didn't think it was
killing them
the [ __ ] plane
the plane came through
and then the [ __ ] flock of birds just
so happen to be [ __ ] you know
covering them covering the plane you
know they're just hover [ __ ] waiting
for another thing
they're just [ __ ] all right there's
a huge spot right
oh what the [ __ ] bro
but yes you could see feathers but you
could see blood it's just bird poop in
there
it's
[Laughter]
what else do they need
you know what's funny all they do is
[ __ ] fly around and [ __ ] the plane
didn't shut down it was still able to
operate it was yeah there was
they couldn't see but i think they were
already landing uh in this routine stop
but yeah they just had to fly and
[ __ ] land so they did emergency
landing in italy i think that most of
the time like they're on autopilot
anyway when they're doing you know even
even with landing and stuff like that
like they go over to manual control but
it's still kind of like semi-automated
right so i think it's like not too crazy
but at the end of the day when you see
like your entire windscreen fully
covered in bird guts you can't even see
you guys have never hit a bird when
you're driving a bird no close i'm not
like really big mosquito you've never
seen a bald eagle just try to go for it
that's bonus point
that is true though because sometimes
you'll be looking on the grill of like a
semi and just like how the [ __ ] did that
sparrow get in there
you know it's like is that a pontiac no
it's just a bird
so they said they said uh the right hand
engine suffered a compressor stall after
the birds were hit and the left-hand
engine also suffered some pretty gnarly
damage during the incident also the
birds suffered death
like they don't give a [ __ ] about the
bird
they try to make a bird slurpee dude
that's [ __ ] up
yo
something similar happened like to this
when i used to work uh in shipping right
like one of the warehouse workers went
out
and he did one of those oh what does
this button do and it basically rolls up
the gate and to one of the bay doors
so he [ __ ] flipped a switch but there
was a bird's nest in the back of the
roll-up door so
we just heard
oh my god at the bottom as it was
rolling up [ __ ] bird chunks poop
body part just [ __ ] severed head
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
the claw like feathers all that [ __ ]
came down it was like it was like a
pinata just like a bird park's just
[ __ ] falling apart and everyone's
like what the [ __ ] we had a squeamish
guy that [ __ ] had a puke like oh it
was
so gross dude that's like a that's a
built-in bird omelette because there's
eggs you could just put it in a pan
dude i was like what the [ __ ] you know
little nest pieces falling down oh good
thing i'm putting kids around imagine
seeing that [ __ ] i know dude everyone
was like no no no it's
just [ __ ] fat flat and i was like
what the [ __ ] and it was just pop oh it
was so gross
yeah it was [ __ ] one of the weirdest
things i've ever seen bird shouldn't
have put its nest there yeah [ __ ]
dumb ass bird yeah
i lost my deposit in my old apartment
because when i moved out they're like a
bunch of birds built a nest in the
balcony why is that your fault yeah what
the [ __ ] i didn't clean it up when i
left and then they i lost my deposit
because of that what the [ __ ] the whole
[ __ ] family well some of them were
dead it was like a family of birds that
built a nest when i was out of town did
you kill him i didn't kill him but you
shouldn't pay for it then [ __ ]
haven't even damaged the property right
yeah sitting on top of it in the
contract it's supposed to look exactly
as it did what if they
made that damn nest while you were [ __ ]
after you cleaned up in the lab
that's the conspiracy right there yeah
this [ __ ] because like just because i
left a family of birds isn't that crazy
i'm supposed to do what happened i think
you [ __ ] lived under a slum lord and
they try to find any excuse
to take your damn deposit because that's
what happens when you left your birds on
the balcony
you're boring oh deposit for you man
come on come on shitty [ __ ] slumlord
man
these particular these particular birds
this flock of birds are herons you guys
familiar with herons they're the ones
with the big ass beaks they're bigger
herons are [ __ ] okay so i don't know
why i had this weird phase uh probably a
couple years ago where i loved watching
heron videos on youtube that is a weird
face specifically
because they [ __ ] give no [ __ ]
parents are the most gangster birds in
like the [ __ ] bird king what makes
them so gangster you okay so the ones
with long beasts they just kind of walk
around like [ __ ] boss they don't give
a [ __ ] about anything like look around
in the dirt and then they'll like spear
a gopher or like a catfish or some [ __ ]
and they'll just swallow the whole thing
this is an animal can be like
the size of their entire body and and
their throat is too small but they'll
swallow the whole thing you never seen
the [ __ ] how big are they typically oh
wait i see are they white feathers uh
they're they're both blue and and white
are they the ones that have like a big
old pouch underneath yeah yeah they're
the pouch not pelicans it's the pelicans
not pelicans that's a store girl similar
so but like they're like one of the most
famous one of the videos you sound like
a hip-hop animal show
check it out this is a stork yo i'm
brian fellow shit's a [ __ ] albatross
have you ever seen a vulture do this
but but these parents will like [ __ ]
eat like uh there's a viral video on
youtube you should look it up this heron
will like uh just go after ducklings
right so there's like a mom they're
cannibals they're [ __ ] dude ducklings
right and then this mom is like
constantly trying to [ __ ] like stop
her this heron from eating her family
and this this hair is one by one picking
up jesus anthony lee you're dark bro
you're watching heron just murder other
animals it's so dark it's [ __ ] up it's
really fun you like it it was just
really entertaining i'm gonna pull one
out i'm trying to say that that this
airplane accident happened because they
were just like hey
like they don't give a [ __ ] they fly
into airplanes bro yeah they thought
they could fight the airplane yeah you
try to eat it
the first video online
these [ __ ] oh wait that's a duck
eating a duck right now that's a big ass
bird that's a duck eating a [ __ ]
duckling yeah it's a duckling right
there so they'll just grab it and then
that's a fish that's a fish so that was
eating a fish you got to see him eat
something that's like his size they
don't miss huh
it's two for two how do you have the
precision to pick a fish out of water
i'm telling you guys gotta see this
[ __ ] thing eat like a [ __ ] that is
pretty impressive though right it's
[ __ ] up but it's really fun to watch
people just kill off like really really
cute cuddly animals so oh i love how
people always romanticize nature like
regular dark though when you when you
watch these do you like jack off like
laugh
at oh [ __ ] people like like a flying
snake is that a gopher look at that guy
just found a gopher and ate it wow
that's sad y'all they just swallow them
whole because they don't got like teeth
and [ __ ] like that just [ __ ] swallow
them he doesn't even know how to savor
his food
i know that's not he's not a foodie
look at that guy dude
water helps wash down it's like what
kind of gopher did you have i don't know
man i just swallowed it
[Laughter]
she's still alive and [ __ ] did you have
the field gopher or the river going ugh
i don't know man i just ate the thing
telling you guys if you guys ever get
into it just [ __ ] youtube parents
eating [ __ ] it's like it seems weird
gophers aren't that hard to [ __ ]
bribe though man i made friends at the
park dude last one last one last one
semi worth it last one check us out
[ __ ] stalks his prey
oh my god wow stabbed hannah who stuck
his whole head in the water
whoa
gosh it's a catfish dude stabbed it
is that arowana he's gonna eat that yo
that shit's half of its body
won't even [ __ ] literally chew it
will it have to eat one more time in
life after that [ __ ] yeah
like the whole lifespan this is probably
the appetizer that was a water that was
a flying animal it literally speared it
like you said yeah that's what i'm
saying and it literally will swallow the
whole thing and just this is why you
look up to herons this is why i respect
them he looks up to them
they're heroes
[Laughter]
he's like baby i'm gonna swallow you
whole yeah
after i stab you first can you treat me
like a heron
my god he killed him
again dude that's what i'm saying he's
got to stab it he's got to bring it over
let's see this [ __ ] deep throw this
[ __ ] all right you want to see some
real deep though it's like anthony it's
our anniversary i'll let you treat me
like a heron
anthony only likes animals that swallow
things
i know you guys are mad intrigued right
now though i am it is i love it i love
nature dude i'm more intrigued and you
follow nature's metal yes i do i love
that page look at this [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] he's gotta slide it in he's gotta
go ahead i'm more intrigued by your
intrigue of this yeah because i never
would have thought you would like this
kind of [ __ ] i wanna see some vegans
protesting at this heroin this is very
specific too the fact that you knew the
breed of the bird it was like oh i have
videos
for you
if you follow nature's metal and you
don't watch it like this like look at
this first of all
okay wow
you're sashimi you mainly like the
throat aspect
do you like that when the when the hair
is swallowing the animal you can kind of
see the animal in the throat
[Laughter]
anthony's anthony's deep throat zoo
wow and then afterwards you just bust
damn
it makes you not feel as bad now yeah
yeah yeah just eat those birds you see
you need you need contacts for all
herons those are all hands on the
windshield
everybody go youtube herron eats go for
a duckling catfish anything everybody
gotta eat man not everyone's gonna eat
[ __ ] plants all day
i'm just saying sick as [ __ ] animals get
deep though too i know man everyone
gotta eat seriously
why do you like bald eagles oh because
they're majestic when they fly hey why
do you like herons their swallowing
abilities
deep throat kings dude
dtf
oh man i love throat birds wait that's
okay seriously
anthony anthony will take the like the
big penis thing to another level man the
only thing that could swallow me is a
herring
[Music]
you